[Music]
my mom is 100% convinced she has been
having a romantic online relationship
with a very famous actor and director is
this famous actor and director asking
her for money yes how did you
[Music]
know what up what up what up this is
John with the Dr John delone
show the show for you about you and your
family and your friends and your
marriage and where you work and what's
going on in your kids schools whatever
you got going on this show is about you
and it's for you my name is Dr John
delone and actually my name is John I
went to school for a long long long time
and they gave me a certificate in a robe
and so I get to put doctor in front of
it but that's not my name my mama Nam me
John my name is John deloney and I've
been sitting sitting with hurting people
for the last two decades and I don't
always have the answers but I promise
I'll show up and I'll sit with you and
we will figure out what's the next right
move for
you and you only because at the end of
the day despite all the chaos with our
kids and our spouses and our friends the
only things we can control is us our
thoughts and our actions if you want to
be on the show go to John dooney.com
askask and fill out the form and it goes
to Jenna and Kelly and they will decide
your fate or you can give me a buzz at
1844 693
3291 don't forget go to john.com
anxiety test not to be diagnosed we're
not doing any Diagnostics but if you're
struggling with burnout if you're
struggling with just just that chronic
Buzz that never stops just that Rippling
anxiety through your home through you
through your kids go take the anxiety
test I'm not even going to ask for your
email address it's not what it's for
it's not like a grab this is just a gift
where are some areas in your life where
you might be um your body may be
sounding the alarms to try to get your
attention right go to john.com anxiety
test and check it out no ask no nothing
this just a free a free give um I know
everybody's struggling and if you're not
struggling you're married to somebody or
you're in love with somebody or you're
working next to somebody who is and so
go take the test and give yourself some
common language at the end of the show
we're going to listen to y's your uh
y'all's results I can't wait to see it
yep we all took the anxiety test and
y'all are an anxious
crew mainly because the guy you work
with is not so stable not so stable
let's go out to Columbus Ohio and talk
to Mill what's up
Mill he good morning Dr John good
morning to you how are you I'm good
what's up I'm so I'll leave with my
question I'm a little nervous I am too
I'm superx I should be taking that
anxiety test right about now it would
tell you the results of your anxiety
test would be talking to a not very
talented middleof the road podcaster and
asking life wisdom so that's what it
would tell
you all right my question is how do I
know the difference between my nervous
system response that seems to drive the
ship hijack everything and what is a
true sense my gut my my intuition and my
knowing um why does let me ask you this
why do you think there needs to be a
difference I don't know I just think
there should be um because I feel like
like I've I've operated from a place
where you know everything's a threat
okay but what if everything is a
threat you're assuming your body's wrong
what if your body's
right is
it
well I I'm I'm coming to the place where
I you know I've been so disconnected
from my body for so many years and I
finally taking it seriously my youngest
son looked at me one day he's 5 years
old and said Mommy why are you such an
angry woman and you know it stopped me
in my tracks was he
right it is I'm yes yes he was right who
disconnected you from your body what
happened oh it's um no a chaotic house
parents who were my parents were adult
children of
Alcoholics um they had no they just
didn't know what they were doing and
building a business building a very
successful um it was just I was on my
own some sexual abuse when I was young
um but just always feeling that I was
there's just no like really we grew up
more like employees than children I
think hey when you experienced um that
sexual abuse did you tell anybody when
you were a kid no no okay all
right and that's that's that that's
nothing to be ashamed of um I was just
wondering if you told somebody and they
didn't believe you or they didn't
respond but almost worse is you were
left completely on your
own and I knew that was no one to tell I
mean there was no okay at that age you
know it's a very young age but hold on
there's another side to
that there should have
been and Trauma can be what happened to
you and Trauma can also be what didn't
happen to you and should have
100% and Trauma like the way Dr mate
just like defines it and I love it
trauma is simply a disconnection from
yourself
and I hate that for
you I don't think there's a difference
between your nervous system and your
gut I think they're both trying to keep
you safe because the people that were
supposed to keep you safe were too too
interested in their
business and too interested in trying to
learn new tools for how what a
relationship should look like since
their parents didn't have
any
and you had a little girl dealing with
sexual abuse and dealing with isolation
and loneliness and being left behind for
work and that little girl went and got
married and had kids right well we're
not married we've been together 15 years
and I still don't married him
why I don't
know you do why not comes out it come I
don't I
just why don't you think you are worth
that security
and I know it's cool to say like because
we're all modered and hip like I don't
even need that bro it's just like I
don't need a piece of paper to tell
me I've been saying that for years
what's that protecting you
from I think the disappointment if it
doesn't work out there you go it's 15
years yeah it's a long time here three
kids we have two kids together I'm
raising a beautiful bonus kid from a
previous relationship he has and we have
a beautiful life we have would he marry
you would he marry you
tomorrow right like this week I'm not
sure hey I I just realized I've just
been talking I heard my friend
Mel really unsure of
Mel and I don't even know why you called
yet but I just want to take some time at
the beginning of this call to tell you
you may not believe in you but I
do and and I'm building that I've I've
really been intentional I've lost 75
pounds smokes that's amazing I'm sit
sitting in the Y parking lot right now
um well that's awesome a good enough
therapist not great but hey that's what
I am I'm good enough I'm not a therapist
but good enough YouTuber and then I I
have a life coach and I my partner and I
went to the summit of greatness a couple
weeks ago here in Columbus I was just
with Lewis uh in Los Angeles last week
awesome yeah yeah yeah
yeah so there's a lot of good stuff here
but there's this part of me that you
know and as
I I thought I had processed all my
trauma and all my stuff I've been you
know kind of doing that for years but
I've numbed out with a lot of things
over the years and um you know our
problems in our relationships certainly
aren't one-sided I guess they never
are but um how can I help you
today
well I mean you answer my question that
my gut and my my intuition don't have to
be or my nervous system don't have to be
two separate
things I think it's fear and just taking
that chance but my girls looked at me
one day and they're like Mom we're never
getting married and we're never having
kids yeah they're 12 years and 13 years
old
and you know what we've shown them what
I've shown them what it is to
be
[Applause]
I am now how to complete that thought
because it just hits me in
my I think I think I think when you
start to get well you start
to I'm going to send you copy of my new
book building an unanxious life but I I
pre-ordered it oh you did I G send you
another one how about that I appreci I
appreciate you doing that
um but the first thing you have to do is
you have to choose reality here's the
truth of my
life these things happen to me these are
the choices I'm making and the work
you've been doing going to counseling um
really honoring yourself being such a
good Steward of Mel losing 75 pounds
that's amazing spending
money with your 15year
boyfriend father of your kids going to
like something great like the summit of
greatness with Lewis and his in his game
like that's awesome but what it does is
it kind of it serves
as a refining fire and it burns off all
the acccess nonsense and what you are
sitting with is
reality you've been pretending you're
not married for 15 years you're as
married as the day is
long you're pretending that you're safe
because you're not in under some
Covenant yet you've created humans
and what you're starting to see of the
reality of your life is you've lived
your whole life with one foot out of the
boat to protect you and in so doing your
kids don't have a stable place a firm
foundation to stand
on the guy who's your husband probably
legally at this point um also doesn't
have a firm place to stand
on and by the way all this work you've
been doing you go to something like the
summit of greatness it should shake you
up you leave really pumped up and you go
home and you look at your house when you
walk in the door from a trip like that
and you go H that's right that's
good because now your next thing is I
got to start making these changes that I
learned about and I've been learning
about and I'll say this I don't think
your nervous system is wrong I think
it's doing what it was what it grew to
do which is to protect you
you but it's protecting you something
from something now that doesn't exist
anymore and that is somebody who's
abusing you that is somebody who's
neglecting you unless I'm Wrong Am I
Wrong no there's definitely neglect in
this relationship okay so not able to
express what I need what my needs are
why not hyper independent hold on hold
on hold on hold on you're not able to
express them because you're going to get
hit in the mouth you're not able to
express them because your husband's a
child and he'll go drink six beers and
leave you for a weekend or you're not
able to express them because you choose
not to say them out
loud that and if I I have expressed my
my needs in the past and it turns into a
you know he might disappear for a day or
a week
or um real stonewalling when so maybe
let's Circle all the way back to the
beginning when you just started talking
and I just felt in my guts I needed to
interrupt you maybe your body's right
this is not a guy to marriage
if a man can make two babies with a
woman and she can't say hey I need this
without him throwing a temper tantrum
and taking off for a
day it's not
safe not safe that means you're dating a
child literally a child trapped in a
man's body and
if I'm
him and I'm watching the woman that I
love
drown cuz she still has chains around
her feet and arms and shoulders and
waist from when she was 6 years old and
she won't tell me how to help it's
exhausting it's so frustrating because
he feels
useless that's it and he tries to help
he doesn't know
how and your daughter sees this pingpong
match between you two and they're like I
don't want any part of that and you know
intuitively they're going to miss out on
the best part of life which is finding
somebody and you look at them and say
I'm all in if you are not somebody
perfect not the quote unquote the one
because that's not real but someone who
says I'll I'm in if you are and they go
all right and that's the best part of
life and the part that gets you hurt the
most because you expose yourself the
most to that person but they've said I
don't want any of
that and what they did was they held a
mirror up to you and you were able for
the first time after this healing to
see wait a minute I'm worth more than
this
too is that
fair fair do you believe you're worth
more than that because I do I do I I
didn't for a long time and I spent a lot
of time drowning it out man a lot of
things I'm so proud of you
and like every single person I've ever
sat
with from high school kid to under
undergraduate to graduate students to
parents
to elderly folks who just lost their
spouse I asked the same question when we
get to this moment what are you going to
do
now
you want me to give you some
starters yes
please starter number one is to tell I'm
just going to call him your husband
because I don't play those kind of games
um you're going to tell your
husband um you and I on Saturday we're
going out for a half
day because uh I've been doing a lot of
counseling I've lost 75 pounds you lost
my
daughter I know that's
amazing um and I she's always like Dad
piggyback ride piggyback ride and just
going up and down the stairs two or
three times I work out a lot too
much and even I'm like man I need you to
get down get off it's too heavy you lost
my daughter
yeah and you've been going to counseling
not a great counselor but good
enough you're investing yourself and I
think you I want you to tell your
husband I want to go spend a few
hours for the first time
ever looking out to
2033 and saying we're we're going to be
at
2033 whether we want to or not and my
daughter is going to be 23 years old and
22 years
old and we have an opportunity right now
to build the life that we want when
they're 22 and 23 are they going to want
to come
home are we going to be talking about
some hot new thing she's dating and
she's planning a m a wedding what or
we're GNA do be doing something else but
you get to decide
that and I want you to tell
them we need to have some hard
conversations about truths if you're not
attracted to me anymore I need you to
bring that with you if you don't want to
be with me anymore I need you to bring
that with you I'm going to bring what I
need and I can't have you running away
and he's just aay present with me even
when it gets
hard and if he says I ain't doing that
then you've heard me say this on the
show a bunch behaviors a
language
yeah then he's telling you I'm not
interested in you growing
I'm not interested in you getting well I
liked my old life where I felt Superior
to you because you were 75 lounds
heavier than you are now I liked my old
life when I could complain about
everything before you started going to
trauma counseling and
healing when one person in a in in a
relationship like this starts doing a
lot of work on their own it disrupts the
equili ium of the home the homeostasis
it changes the dynamic of everything and
sometimes without meaning to the other
partner will try to bring the other
person back somebody loses 75 pounds and
all a sudden someone's like let's just
order a pizza showing up with donuts on
a Saturday morning they get up really
early they put gas in your car for the
week and they go grab a dozen donuts
just because a you've been working so
hard it's this weird subconscious thing
I need things back the way they were
even though back the way they were I
didn't like it I wasn't com comfortable
my partner was sick all the time I
didn't no one was comfortable we're just
there and so to keep that thing from
getting dragged back from keep you from
getting pulled back or just getting shot
out like a rubber band this whole
thing's over 15 years three kids it's
all just
over it's important to just go take some
time change the environment change the
location and say let's be adults let's
put everything on the table and let's
make a choice are we going to build
something new are we going to keep
building something
new or is my body telling me the truth
this is not somebody who's safe to be
with long term this is not somebody to
build a life with and I've been playing
for the last
decade and I think you look across the
table in a very scary vulnerable way
probably more vulnerable than you've
been since you were a young little kid
and you say this is what I need and this
is where I want to
go do you still love me and will you
still be here because he might say
no but he might say
yes and so goes love and so goes
marriage and so goes romantic
relationships do you see all of me and
do you see where I want to go and do you
see who I'm becoming
and do you still love me
too
[Music]
you're worth it Mel you're worth
it write down the questions you want to
ask him write down your
needs and invite him to a dreaming
breakfast and
lunch call me back after that meeting
I'm I I'll be here with you every step
of the way I'm so so proud of you the
hard work is still to come but man you
have launched out like a rocket we'll be
right
back hey good folks delone here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time those become healthy
habits they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Hall is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com delone today to start your free
trial just follow the simple prompts at
hall.com
dealone for 90 days
free all right let's go out to Detroit
Rock City Home of Eight Mile and talk to
Paul what's up Paul hey how's it going
rocking on man what are you up
to um not a whole lot um I just want to
say uh thank you for taking my call and
letting me um be on the show with you
you got it man thanks for trusting me
and give me a buzz what's up um so my
question is is I've been married for 20
years but it feels like for the last 10
years I've been living under a rock and
I've been oblivious to things that have
been going on in my house with my wife
my relationship with my kids but at the
same time it also feels like no matter
what I do I have um goalposts that are
moving so um I'll try my best I'll do
things to make everyone happy but then
it was there was something else that I
missed or something else that I didn't
do and that's causing a lot
of
um communication issues and conflicts in
my household and I'm trying to be the
best person I can be however I keep
failing short over and over and over
against whose
standard um against my wife's standard
okay when you say I want to be the
better person so that way I can support
her in that role I got that it's
important to put truth on the table
though okay okay like I I I'm not going
to I don't doubt your sincerity for a
second and I think you're a good man
okay I'm going to start there okay um
and sometimes it's hard to say the truth
about our partners like hey this is
actually happening or this person is
really hard to be with or this person
keeps moving the goalpost on me every
time I think I've understood the rules
of the game the rules change I thought
we were playing basketball now playing
football and so it's important to do
both when you say you've been living
under a rock what does that mean that
you were oblivious for a decade of what
was going on in your house what does
that mean yeah so it means like um I
know I thought everything was you fine
um you know we had a good relationship I
had a good relationship with my kids and
then it turns out we had um a
miscommunications and my wife is like
listen our youngest one is 17 he
graduates this year after this year I
don't have to stay married to you no
more I can go out on my own we don't
have any kids holding us together we
have nothing it's just a matter of if I
want to be with you or not and that is
scaring me especially when I know I keep
coming up short whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa dude
whoa do I have permission to just speak
honestly and openly okay is that okay
yes so I'm going to say some things that
are going to make you mad and they
should but I feel like I need to say
them is that okay absolutely I don't
know that you've been living under a
rock as much as your wife has been lying
to you for 10
years okay I don't know that you're
failing I can't if I if you tell me
we're playing basketball and I show up
with my short shorts and my tall socks
in a basketball and I start dribbling
and putting it in the
net
and somebody comes with a football
helmet and hits me I'm not failing at
the game of football We're Playing
Basketball okay I don't think you're
failing at some standard it sounds like
your wife doesn't want to be married to
you and she's riding out her
clock and there's nothing you can do if
you're with a partner that doesn't want
to be with you anymore
more okay is that fair tell me I'm wrong
no that I I get that that's fair who in
the world would look at their spouse and
say ha now that the kids are gone now
it's up to
me
what as opposed to hey we got one year
left with knucklehead number three and
after this you and I get to recreate
this whole
thing we get to imagine a life we
haven't had for 20 years 22 years
however long old your oldest kid is yep
and we get to do whatever we want
whenever we want minus College tuition
payments right
right and your wife chose that moment to
weaponize that that that moment of
vulnerability yeah I didn't look at it
that way I always figured yeah you're so
beat down for so long that every time
there's a problem you immediately say
I'm so sorry what did I do I'll fix it
I'll make it right yeah absolutely
that's what I try to do and the fact is
is she didn't want me to fix it she
wanted me just to listen and hear her
and I haven't done that I've always went
to fix it mode oh that's fair that's
fair so I know I've made plenty of
mistakes on the communication side where
I didn't hear I didn't listen and well
and she did too she didn't tell you
my wife gave me the gift about seven
years ago stop trying to fix my problems
I'm smarter than you I just want you to
listen to
me will you be well my wife has said
that stuff and I didn't listen to well
then you're lot my
problem there you go then you're knuckle
but absolutely so here we
are is it too late for me is what I
because I've been trying my hardest off
I've s SE the counselor I've been
listening to your podcast I've found um
several other podcasts none none of what
I have to say what other podcasts have
to say or what your therapist has to say
matters okay the only thing that matters
is can you sit across from your wife and
say are you
interested in building the back half of
our life together into something
Incredible or do you want to
leave and if you tell her I'm all in
and she says I don't I'm done I've been
dreaming of this moment for six years I
just went into a quiet phase I just I
just locked myself in ice for six years
to ride out the
clock okay but all these other voices
unless your wife has given you a very
clear list here's what I need if if you
want to stay married to me here's what I
need and by the way you get to say what
you need
too all right understood when's the last
time you did
that um I had a conversation with her
about two weeks ago it's like okay what
do you need and then she laid it out she
listen I need to spend more quality
one-on-one time with the kids more time
with her and we started doing some of
those tasks how's that going um I think
so far they're going good
um I travel a lot for work just last
night we spent a bunch of time over on a
video phone going over some um you know
these these cards that we got and we had
good conversations so I think it's
starting aw I'm just not
sure could it be that you are unsure of
your worth outside of your
utility I asked that in kind of a nerdy
highbrow way I'm sorry yep nope nope
nope yes that could definitely be
because you know this is my whole world
here so how old are you um I am 42 okay
one of the most common2 been married for
20 years so one of the most common
questions or conversations I have with
40-year-old men and 50-year-old Men
Behind Closed Doors
is if I'm not my
answers what am
I
and the hardest thing to reconcile is
you wired into your nervous system is
men are only as valuable as the crap
they can
do
period And I reject that wholeheartedly
because it's killing a generation of
men is there a set of skills that a man
needs to learn
1,000% no question about it
and does a man have more value than just
the tasks he can check off a list
yes and it sounds like what your wife is
trying to tell you is in all of your
performing and all of you're trying to
get it
right it's like it's like an actor
looking for a script and she's like I
don't want you to be Shakespeare I just
want
you okay is that that makes sense yeah
that makes sense and so I think when you
say what what do you need I think it'd
be fair to come back and say hey I've
been thinking the best way I can show up
for you
all and give you full
presence exhale real big is to know I've
got value
to and so I'm going to trust you that if
you want my advice if you want me to
give give you like a an answer or to
look up directions or something like
that or look up the mortgage rates or
the tax code if you want that that
you'll be very clear and ask me for
it and what I'm going to do is I'm going
to release myself from that
responsibility because you're
brilliant and you're my wife and I trust
you to ask for it and I'm going to
practice just showing up to listen
because we're
friends
okay I guess that's where I've been
failing in the past stop
dude if I showed up to a
job to fix a house and I open my toolbag
and all I have is a
hammer and all they have to hang the
drywall with is
screws and so I do this job with
hammering screws through
drywall it will be loose and not
straight
but I say I did a great job no can I say
I did the best job with the tool I had
yes did I fail No in fact I may have
accomplished something pretty
significant I hung drywall with a
hammer okay that's pretty dang
impressive I'm not a failure what I do
need though is new tools and new
training and I'm probably going to have
to redo that
garage but I did a pretty impressive job
with a hammer
you my friend have to stop referring to
yourself as a failure every time you
don't get something
right I guess that's extremely hard to
do because I've been saying that for so
long I know or I've been feeling it that
for so long now and you can't possibly
expect somebody else to love you and to
fully plug into you if you hate
you there's nothing for them to plug in
too okay you're an outlet that with no
electricity you have to love yourself
enough to go to the gym I love myself so
much that I'm going to be a good Steward
of this 42y old body I love myself
enough that I'm going to get a full
night's sleep so I can show up for my
kids one-on-one plugged in I'm going to
close my stupid laptop when I'm at home
turn my dumb phone off when I'm at home
and if I I don't have a boss that
doesn't believe in home time I'm going
to quit my job I'm going to make it a
over the next 365 days I'm going to
begin to turn the ship and get do
something new because my family's not
worth losing all
that exactly 100% I agree with that yes
but what we're doing here is we're not a
failure dude you have just been building
a house with only a hammer it's pretty
impressive I don't know how you manage
to saw all that wood with a hammer you
figured it out it looks Terri terrible
but you did
it right okay yes
yep make it a commitment today make it a
commitment today tell your kids this
will be a fun a fun way to connect with
your kids how old are your kids um I
have two 23 year olds a 20- year old and
a 17 year old awesome how much do you
make a year what's your annual take-home
um over 100,000 a year great this is
going to be a fun game
I want you to tell all of your kids in a
phone message hey
guys I'm realizing that I talk to myself
worse than I would ever let anybody talk
to somebody
else and because I think have thought so
little of myself for so long it's rubbed
off on all you guys and I'm sorry for
that from this day forward to my 22 and
23 year old kids my older
kids I'm going to send you a check for
$100 every time you catch me saying I
was dumb or I'm stupid or I failed that
I screwed
up to your younger kids I'm going to
send you a check I'm GNA give you cash
$50 and come up with something special
between you and your wife and they will
smile and they get to catch them they
get to be a part of their dad
reimagining his relationship with
himself and it's going to cost a couple
hundred bucks and you're going to quit
real
quick okay so it's
$100 for my older kids for any time I
say I was a failure and $50 to my
youngest anytime somebody says something
crappy about their dad okay that happens
to be their dad right and sit down with
your wife and say I
realize I've thought so little of myself
for so long I didn't think I was worth
you loving
me and and I thought so little of myself
for so long I thought the only value I
would bring to our kids is a paycheck
that would direct deposit and I'm just
going to work on the road and get out of
the way so y'all can live a great life
cuz I kind of
suck and I want you to tell your wife
you're sorry for thinking so little of
the man she
married okay and tell her that you're
going to
commit to reimagining your relationship
with Paul and that's going to be twofold
one of that is going to be standing in
front of the mirror and you're going to
embarrass the crap out of yourself but
you'll be alone and putting a fist in
your chest and looking at the mirror and
saying the words I love this guy 10
times in the morning and 10 times at
night I love this
guy and when you say it you're going to
feel your your your shoulders clinch up
around your neck and then you're going
to consciously drop him and say I love
this guy and you're not just going to
bark mantras like Instagram would tell
you you're also going to go to the gym
you're also going doing that for month
yes good and you're going to get a group
of men to hang out
with and if your wife wants to go see a
counselor you're going to go with her to
see a counselor in fact you may ask hey
would you go to see a counselor with me
yep yep see what I'm saying you're gonna
start not just spouting out mantras
you're going to start with a whole bunch
of tiny little
wins in route to becoming a guy that you
respect
okay you get what I'm saying it's both I
yes I get what you're saying absolutely
um what about when I do fail at a task
or something of that nature you're going
to okay I do all the time did you know
this very show we had to re-shoot the
intro because I screwed it
up that's unfortunate I have a top five
podcast in health and fitness in the
world and I screwed up the intro because
I was just blabbing on about something
that I thought was funny and Kelly
looked at me and she was like that's
clearly not funny at all
and then I tried to get out of it and I
just made it worse and then I started
babbling that's what I do for a living
okay I fail every
day yesterday I put my seven-year-old
daughter's face in my hands and I said
I'm sorry I did this
wrong and she doesn't even she didn't
even say I forgive you I didn't say I
was wrong for her forgiveness I didn't
say I was wrong
for some sort of approval stamp from her
I said I was wrong because I was
wrong I fail every day Paul every day
okay it's part of Being
Human the test of a man the test of a
woman too but in this case I'm just
talking to a man so the test of a man in
this moment is are you going to get back
up are you going to own your mistakes
and you're going to go make them
right and the other the person you
wronged they get a say into how you make
things
right okay
and then you go to the mirror and you
put your fist in your chest and you sayi
love this guy and then you go do the
next right
thing I guess I'm just afraid when I do
go to ask that question is what if the
answer is no I don't want to be with you
in a
year the way to guarantee that is to
isolate yourself and not ask that
question and try to sing and dance your
way to your wife's
approval
okay
and maybe you take her out to breakfast
and you say hey
um I've tried to love you through my
insights and wisdom and
knowledge and I've tried to love you
through my bank account I tried to love
you
through making sure you had all your
needs
met and that's left you feeling isolated
and
cold I'm going to try to love you by
being honest with you by being
vulnerable with you by telling you what
I need what I'm scared
of I'm going to practice because I've
never done this before and so I'll ask
you to be gentle with me and be kind to
me as I'm figuring this
out and Kids when you catch your old man
talking bad about himself I'm going to
pay
you honey if you catch me talking bad
about your husband will you call me on
it like you would a
stranger and don't try to do this on
your own your wife sounds like she's
giving you a road
map follow the road map and she needs a
road map too she's told you how to love
you I think it's fair for you to say
here's how I need to be love in this new
marriage we're
building call anytime my brother thank
you so so much for trusting me and for
being vulnerable I'm proud of you hang
on the line I'm going to send you two
copies to building a non- anous life I
want you and your wife to both read them
youall can build a road map together on
how to build a less anxious house and in
so doing I'm confident you're going to
be able to find some things that y'all
can talk about
together it's going to bring up some new
needs and new wants that y'all can do
together I'm proud of you man thanks for
the call we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey folks Delona here sometimes we
know what's good for us but it feels
like we just can't make ourselves do it
like our brain's getting in its own way
and that happens to me a lot and I'm
pretty sure it happens to you I know I
should play a game with my kids instead
of practicing my guitar all night but
sometimes my brain tells me that hey
maybe that metal band's going to call
after all you got to get your practice
in therapy helps me figure out what's
holding me back from doing what I know I
should do and it can help you too so
your brain can begin to work with you
not against you
sometimes it's just as simple as talking
things through and learning how to
intentionally Place guard rails between
yourself and negative behaviors we call
them boundaries so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give betterhelp a try
betterhelp is flexible because it's
totally online so it can fit your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist you can switch
therapist at any time for no extra
charge make your brain your friend with
better help visit betterhelp.com delone
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com all right let's go out to Lake
City Florida and talk to the Great and
Powerful Lauren what's up
Lauren yes hi Dr John how are you I'm
good how are you I am great great I
can't complain yes you could but then
you'd be like Kelly so who wants
that what's up true so I need your help
got it um I have the situation with my
mother and I have not heard this
addressed on your show before I did some
Googling didn't come across it I
apologize if you've addressed it but
anyway it's all right not every show is
made it up on the Google so it's all
good what's
up so my mom is 100% convinced that she
has been having a romantic online
relationship with a very famous um actor
and director and it's been going on for
few months
now and she doesn't believe me or anyone
else who she's talked to we're trying to
convince her she's being
scammed and is this famous actor and
director asking her for
money yes how did you
know because very I bet you can even I
bet you can even guess in what form oh
jeez it's so it's a little funny at
first no it's heartbreaking it's it's
very tragic these things happen a lot
and terrible lonely elderly folks just
get taken for everything it's truly
devastating
um how old is your
mom she is 71 okay are you on her she
has been are you on her accounts is this
like a power of attorney no
okay and here's what I'm thinking I'm
wondering about an end
round and this is somewhat deceptive and
I'm okay with it um sitting down and
having a conversation not about her
boyfriend and not about the person she's
in love with or all that but hey you're
71 is she is she single by the way yes
okay is your dad still alive he passed
away passed away okay um just making
sure hey if something happens to you
just want to make sure
um make sure that you're safe make sure
that that I've got access to your
accounts that I
could get you the treatment that you
needed or the care that you
needed right um my sister I have a
sister that lives in the same state with
my mom so she is on she does have access
to her accounts and things like that so
she's been trying to like watch and make
sure that you know mother hasn't given
money away and all this but um we have
tried the power of attorney talk before
and she hasn't really okay been super
open to that yet she's a very stubborn
woman as we want as we want our moms to
be except when they're giving famous
actor money
right
um here's the hard thing man I think
this is the hardest thing in the world
to do outside
of physical or sexual
abuse is watching a loved one somebody
we care deeply deeply about make
decisions that we know are actively
harming
them
and it's very very
hard um I'm think sitting here thinking
of can you reach out to William Mor
agency or CAA or one of these places and
see and let them know hey here's some
emails here's some Facebook exchanges
somebody scamming my mom is there
something you could do so I even
reported it to Facebook because because
Facebook care they just care about
getting rid of antivaxers they don't
care they want to shut down mask videos
and antivaxers they don't care um so I I
I I I mean maybe appeal to the their
agent you're probably not going to get
anywhere there um um the only other
thing I could think of is finding
somebody in your community that you or
in that community and maybe your sister
could help um a police officer who would
make a call to your mom or come visit
your
mom yeah so we tried that too actually
one of one of my niece's has a friend in
town same town um and he shared that
there had been a case where this person
was out like a quarter million dollars
and there was literally nothing they
could do because it's not illegal to
convince somebody to give you money not
until they I'm saying like have the
police officer go to your mom and say
Hey I want to let you know somebody's
been impersonating famous actor and
Director X and asking people for money
it is a legitimate scam and it's taking
advantage of people and I just wanted to
warn you about it yeah maybe and
somebody shows up in a uniform maybe
that's the thing but the draw wor a shot
the draw will be so
powerful yeah and she's she's lying to
us and manipulating her grandkids she's
in love she's in love with somebody
special yeah and you so much information
is accessible online now that people can
find out everything about everybody I
know and so she could ask a hard
question and this person could Google it
and answer it exactly right so I mean
you can't fight you can't logically
fight an illogical
person right and she is so caught up in
love and in feeling special and feeling
seen by somebody that she deems
important that it's overriding
everything it's a
drug
yeah similar to somebody who's
struggling with alcohol who stops
showing up to family things abandons
their kids or somebody who's struggling
with heroin or opiates Lo just abandons
everybody it's not a it's not a rational
move but you're not dealing with
somebody who's seeing the world as it is
you're seeing somebody who's seeing the
world through a glass Darkly right you
can't see
it and she's been through so much yeah
so much and she's always given and given
and given to all of her kids and her
grandkids and her her great grandkids
Predators love a giver H it's terrible
it's
terrible listen there's literally
outside of making a police report which
I think you should do I think you should
call the police make a formal police
report and see if you can find somebody
who's will show up in a uniform to your
71y old mom's house and sit down and
have a conversation and say this is an
active scam going on we just want you to
be aware of it absent of
that I think you get with your sister
and maybe your sister goes and talks to
the bank and shows them some printouts
of some of these conversations and say
my 70-year-old mother 71y old mother is
actively in the middle of being taken
advantage of is there anything I can do
there's probably not but it's worth the
conversation and it might be since your
sister's power of attorney that I mean
not power of attorney but she's on the
accounts every time there's a a uh an
expense of $500 sent via vinmo she gets
in there and cancels cancels the
transaction as fast as possible maybe
she puts a notice on her phone that
every time there's a transaction she
gets notice of
it and she just cancels the
transaction but at the end of the
day there's no law there is law against
fraud and there's law against theft but
there's no law against your mom choosing
to spend her
money against the well-meaning wisdom of
everybody who loves her and that's so
heartbreaking
cuz she's going to give a credit card
number or she's going to give over the
VIN number to her car or she's going to
give a social security number and that's
going to be a mess for
everybody but famous actors and famous
directors don't need money from common
folks most of the time I'm so sorry
going through this
Lauren the pool the fantasy is going to
be
tough
some point get as loud as you possibly
can be as clear as you can and then just
tell your mom I'll hold your hand
through this through all the devastation
and heartbreak and it's
coming so so sorry L we'll be right
back hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non ious life you'll
learn the six daily choices that you can
make to get rid of your anxious feelings
and be able to better respond to
whatever life throws at you so you can
build a more peaceful nonanxious life
get your copy today at John
del. all right we are back as promised
the gang in the booth took the anxiety
test all right let's do this what' y'all
come up so let me let me give a primer
if you haven't taken the anxiety test
John gone.com anxiety test it's not
diagnostic it's not going to tell you
you have an anxiety
disorder uh it's not at all what we're
doing here you need to go sit with a
licensed mental health professional to
get that type of diagnostic what this
does is says hey you feel anxious you
feel burned out you feel like you are
always stressed
out using the six daily choices that I
outlined in the book it's going to give
you it's gon to ask you some questions
and it's going to give you um some
arrows some directions hey look over
here will you think that there might be
a fire over here in your living room or
in your kitchen or in your back bedroom
that's setting off the smoke detector in
your house the smoke detector of anxiety
and so it provides some direction here
so you all took it who wants to go first
I'll start all right all right so I had
no Reds which I was oh so and it does
give it gives you red yellow and green
green says and it seems like your body's
humming along yellow looks like I going
to check on that and red is like Yoo
yeah so my two yellows were in
connection which I was honestly a little
shocked about because I have like a
really strong friend group um so I was a
little shocked at that one okay and then
health and healing which I was not at
all shocked about yes yeah cuz I know I
need to work physically you know trying
to lose some weight and stuff and uh I
know that one deals a lot with emotions
and I'm not real good with those tell me
more I like to stuff those down
and pave over you tend to go from
operational to what are you doing yeah
so that's why I've been in counseling
for a year let me let me ask you a a
connection question so you've got a
tight-knit group of friends You' all
been ride or die for a long time over 20
years you also have some ongoing text
threads with different folks that like
are are just like you've got a group
people that are always at at fingers
like touch away right right
and what I'm learning more and more
about loneliness is you can be crowded
lonely in a crowded room you can have
tons of people and look up and it's been
four months since my house flooded and I
moved back in and I got one kid moving
in like I got one kid about to age out I
got one kid here one kid doing this
that's getting real personal my
husband's Like Son of and all of a
sudden like oh I haven't gone and sat
with my girlfriends not like at a
concert or something but sat down and
had coffee like how are you I'm not
great and so it's easy to text and it's
easy to do this and so sometimes that it
feels like we're connected everywhere
but we're actually not connected
anywhere yeah that's legit because we
especially the last six months you know
with the house flooding we lost both of
our mothers it's been a bit of a yes yes
a mess we'll just use that term a that's
how Jesus would have said it exactly
because I can't say the other word on
the air I know um so yeah that's fair
that um you know and and my girls all
live here we're all local but there's
times where like okay y'all it's been a
bit you know one's just gone through a
divorce and so you just look up and
you're like hey it's been a few months
so um it's that it happens a lot in
marriages right you see each other every
day and you'll get busy doing life and
you haven't connected in months yeah
especially because we have you know we
have a very special needs child at home
yes so everything becomes very um
transactional is not the word but
utilitarian you got your job I got my
job because there's certain things that
have to be done there's routines that
have to be followed so that very much
happens that happens with friends too
we're all in the same neighborhood we're
all in the same Community we just text a
lot and all of a sudden it's 6 months
yeah and then your body starts to
quietly go hey hey hey hey and then you
think it's husband or then you think
it's kid and then you think it's Donuts
we'll fix this and you're near America
right all right awesome okay uh who else
took it I'll go all right uh I got I had
three Reds so I I had a red on reality
uh mindfulness and health and healing
which wasn't surprised about that I need
to go to the gym it's it's what it is
for this season um I was surprised okay
then I got two greens for connection and
belief which are kind of related to me
because I've been recently getting
involved with all these small groups
okay worship team and all this stuff
like local church stuff yeah local CH
stuff so it's a little bit connected so
I'm I'm feeling good there I was a
little surprised that I didn't at least
have a yellow on reality cuz I feel like
oh I'm like a grounded person like I'm
you know I take things as ER and except
but then I I started thinking like what
does this mean to to me how do I apply
that and and what I thought of was like
oh yeah when things are uncomfortable
for me I just kind of avoid them and I'm
like oh this thing like as if it doesn't
exist if I just like ignore like phone
calls that I need to make or
appointments I need to make or stuff
that is like overwhelming for me but
it's still there right it's just you
know it's stuff that I just need to deal
with you know that's awesome so um the
way I like to explain choose reality is
your body is solving
for that reality whether you are
actively doing it or not and so you can
be all like out for dinner with your
wife your brain knows we're spending our
time together this is date night your
body knows this marriage is in a mess
right or my wife's doing X and or I'm
showing up at work and I'm on the best
podcast of all time I hate my job right
like your body is solving for that and
so yeah that's the choose reality for
some Reon it's like the motor underneath
the machine is
running like the machine's still going
but it's this H I need to deal with that
yeah totally yeah sorry you hate your
job Ben I'm trying trying this is the
best part of my job geez yeah it's going
back to nine hours of editing because
I'm so terrible at this that you got to
fix all my crap sorry j okay so mine was
almost exactly like Ben's I had three
red it was also reality mindfulness and
health and healing um and then I had two
yellows connection and belief which I'm
kind of in the same boat as Ben where
like we're doing a women's Bible study
right now never done that before I grew
up Catholic and then kind of left the
church for a while and that come back in
the past couple years so for me that's
kind of like a hard jumping back into
like or jumping into actually just in
the first place um and then I also
questioned the reality one at first um
but then I stood back and realized oh no
I'm in a new phase of my life where I'm
pregnant and there's a child in my body
right now and I think I'm still like
sometimes I'm like forgetting like that
at the end of this there's going to be a
baby and so uh your body knows that
everything is different now right but
Jenna just wants to keep doing Jenna yes
yeah and also I've like in the last
couple weeks I've just been like waiting
for like when am I going to feel
movement like what and then it'll become
real like once that happen happens then
it'll be real for me and I think I'm
still kind of in the phase of but your
body knows this is all very real yes
yeah so and what about and don't answer
this but um especially firsttime
parents there's some very real I don't
know if he's going to show up in XY or Z
way or I wonder what this is going to
look like or I have a picture of what we
bring our baby home and it's going to
look like this and I don't think his
picture is going to look like that he's
still going to want to go do his
whatever and so your body is solving for
we don't know we don't know we don't
know and I'm not having that
conversation and he's not we're just
like and all of a sudden you find
yourself right yeah I very much like
control and like knowing what's going to
happen I don't St Jenna really yeah
exactly but but I think that's
where the I like to say that
conversation's going to happen right
it's either going to happen with you
like sobbing holding a baby and him
going I don't know right or it can be at
an
awesome breakfast out somewhere and
you're like all right here's what my
picture of bringing the baby home is
going to look like and he's like whoa
didn't see that coming and you say did
you know that for like the first six
months maybe a year it's like 10 diapers
a day and he'll go what I thought it was
one and you'll be like no like things
like that right and it could be fun and
hilarious and like oh my gosh or it can
be like y'all are walking around the
rubble of your home that once was right
and so either way good for that so tell
me about
mindfulness um yeah so you know I this
one I saw I question a little bit too I
don't know if
it's yeah I guess I just need to dig
into this one more I think I've I've
been digging more into the reality one
and I don't know so the way the
mindfulness for is can be distilled down
into two words awareness and curiosity
okay and most people who are avoiding um
avoiding reality mhm have chosen to make
judgments about things or to ignore
things I'm just going about my day and
so mindfulness is simply being
aware whenever Reed comes in I just want
to leave I to go in the back room I love
that guy I know he loves me he's who I
chose to do life with he's gonna be a
great dad but for some why why is my
body trying to like just bail out of
here that's awareness and the curiosity
is hey can we talk for a minute it's
super weird every time you walk in are
you nervous about having a baby and he'd
be like oh my gosh it's so but that's
it's mindfulness is that it's almost a
path to reality like choosing reality is
like right I don't know why I keep
running out of money every month I make
good money I don't know why I can't I
make enough and that's awareness like I
need to took my budget and curiosity is
like why can't I stop spending even
though I know I don't have that money um
that's mindfulness just being present
with it yeah does that make sense yeah
for sure did you take
it
I didn't I didn't know we were doing
this until today Kelly's just producing
crap out of this show good job Kelly
Kelly Kelly we like to call her Kelly um
the includer Kelly the
includer nobody calls her that hey all
right so go to John dooney.com
anxiety test check it out um post your
results if you're brave and uh I'll go
over my results next time they were very
similar to y'all's lots of Reds lots of
yellows not a lot of green it's a very
anxious season
and it's all good cuz I planned it hey I
love you guys we'll see you soon next
time on the Dr John delone
show